hi my name is Lila hi Lila my question
is for Maisie Williams I just want to
say Allah mimulus about the hiatus thank
you very much well I also wanted to know
what challenges do you foresee going
forward playing aria now that she's
flying and everything um well from the
last thing that we shot with David the
contacts that I was wearing before that
big reveal at the end I did it for one
shot so I would only have him for about
15 minutes and they're really really
thinking really white into your eye but
when what's there really took a couple
of minutes to get me a bit more
comfortable but then there's straight
back how again so I'm worried if I'm
going to have to do any fighting on
anything one I can't see and to the
extremely uncomfortable so yeah I'm
gonna find see what they write in
because it takes them three seconds to
be like REO by exploring but it takes me
a long time to master that so yeah we'll
see we'll see what happens well at least
you will have the driver Cara scissor
come on
hi my name is Jacob my question is for
the incredibly talented and beautiful
Natalie Dormer um so I really like with
Marjorie we finally got to a point in
the story where she's accomplished a lot
of what she set out to do she's become
queen not jockers queen but Tommen who
she didn't persuade getting season five
we didn't see her accomplish love with
this power what can we expect any grand
schemes from Queen Margaery in season
six um well can I will say our cast
years they're gonna have a hard time
answering questions about what's going
to happen moving forward I think that's
probably fair right yeah you're welcome
I tried backstage and they wouldn't tell
me and I'm kind of famous so cheap
company i'm honest honey um I a lot of
us sitting at this table or in exactly
the same position as you guys David and
Dan keep their cards very close to their
chests and I I don't have an effing clue
what's going to happen tomorrow I really
don't all I can tell you is that a
grandma ain't around lagarde to her
anymore and she is in a situation like a
lot of the characters are sitting next
to me they're all in new situations
where they really don't know how they're
going to play their next move so I think
launched wheezing quite a bit of trouble
to be honest a quick question for
Carolyn how do you when you start giving
out scripts you come park mental lives
does everybody see the full script or do
people just see their scenes in there
like city or town you know what it's
saying well everybody gets there
everybody gets all so they do know they
just want to tell you okay they don't
emin they don't just because I get it
doesn't mean the read them yes hey all
right my question is for everyone who's
going to miss kit the most since he's
obviously been anybody anybody get a bit
because even a little bit his
hairdresser q2 we couldn't wait friends
be gone not so lying face probably
always in the shower because you got
shared like one flat right yeah that's
what rich people carbons anyways just
try to fit you guys next one and the
same
right hey right down over that should I
can go one thing that Johnstone but I
have a question for currys never hang
out with our OWSLA mayor and like learn
some cool tricks from then that might
come in handy in the future maybe I mean
as Natalie just pointed out as in the
dark as you all are that's pretty dark I
admit and info tears but who knows been
I can tell you anything sorry he was
pretty just happy to get the shirt out
there
question again soon hey good hi my name
is Elizabeth my question is for
everybody if you could change one thing
about the last season what would it be
like a death or something your character
did hmm I would wait for the candle
thank you take a little bit of
responsibility thank you I'm nishida
waited for the candle light still on the
boss uh yes hello I'm Catherine I do
want to say shame for somebody in the
audience you know who you are and right
everybody up there my question is for
the whole cast is there any stunts that
you wanted to do that your stunt double
gonna do instead I do all my own
I feel kind of guilty because everyone
else like especially Gwendolyn and all
the Warriors fight and have 12 day
scenes and I have an afternoon bitching
was Peter Dinklage so I think apart from
home door I have I have the least
physicality to do so every time that we
see pouring wine that's you porno
trouble yes my name is Joey just wanna
say first off you guys are all great and
love the show just as much I love the
books I'm question for selfie which was
i read an interview that you like that
very controversial scene really thought
it was interesting to film and i was
wondering cuz you know Santa started off
as very naive and innocent character and
from learning from Cersei and from
little finger or she kind of came strong
so I just wondering why it was that they
seen was chosen to focus hey on beyond
and it tells me like it it kind of
diminished I kinda made Sophie so they
kept Santa basically not a strong
character anymore just based on the roof
section of the scene i'm wondering why
you thought it was nothing pronounceable
I'm sorry we're doing that spot no no
there's one thing this sauce is still is
despite what happened to her is strong
ah um I think I really don't know why
they you'll have what's right it's about
that one more than quickest to you
because I was giving you great
I'm not like right I mean I think son
sir yeah she has gone through a lot but
she has you know develop skills from
surgery and monitoring and others and
she's still just as strong as she was
before but again what she's been doing
this whole time this whole series is
she's been kind of just getting by
without doing anything totally radical
because that could you know totally
change her situation she could die I'm
with the Bolton's that's a big risk to
take and I think she knows that she's
not stupid she didn't just think all
right then this is gonna happen I think
she she thought through in her head she
could have fought back if she wanted to
and she didn't um I think that's you
know it's good for her character she
she's one of those characters that kind
of does her scheming in her mind rather
than out early no worries man all right
thank you in advance our next question
act hurt
this wanna ask you all if you ever add
them and if it ever makes an awesome
show you guys every question no no yeah
can you imagine trying to have little
missions like you would never clue what
you were trying to set you can't like
Yemen okay yes it oh my god Ramses the
worst oh yeah going good I don't know
who's worse ramseyer John raining but I
just wanted to ask okay so now that we
have drogon coming out and showing what
he can do and I was wondering so the
other two dragons are still locked up
are they going to kind of take drogon as
like a leader and it kind of because I
know right now Denarius um she can't
really control those drugs but now that
drove ons out so maybe he could actually
kind of become the leader of those
dragons so that they can actually come
out and destroy everyone that's right
you're both roaming that yeah yeah yeah
front yeah so yeah Joseph is the leader
of the Dragons I did not know that back
forth
penguins looks like we got here we go hi
guys you can ask now they're here but
they probably know the answer just the
last drove on he's there just saw the
dragon yeah that's a dragon it's a
dragon and a man who's about to have
back problems hi guys hi so my question
or our question is is there going to
ever be as season finale that's longer
than an hour like nine minutes and more
dragons next season don't build your
Park doing a longer finale well our
every almost every last episode is
longer than now by a minute or two but
me you know they plenty of options out
there let's see what happens thanks guys
thank you hi there hi my question is for
amazing so I think this season you
really turned into like the badass
assassin that you've been like we're
coming but I think one of the most
unintentionally funny moments no offense
was the whole easter thing yeah i mean
yeah that's like a running joke now yeah
so I think if there's two things that
were pretty sick of seeing is sweeping
floors and noises sounds of couples yeah
fella going into the new season there
won't be more training for kids like
them clanton it was just it was Rick
posters and cockles you improvise plan
that was my it made it really made sure
hi there hi Cass hey pretty good fun
question them what's your worst or
funniest I'll take see funny oh I don't
make mistakes I swear a lot of notes em
house was a nightmare I think I think
there is a blooper reel where you see a
little bit of the experience that Dean
Charles and I had that that cat would
not stay on that bed actual as a wonder
my sensor I had an issue with fellow
with a good the cat in season one when r
is chasing the cat and she supposed to
not be able to catch the camera but
everything for to know more like a cat
account under the front of main and I
said I said what do i do if i go over
and cash mccalley such a v1 so in the
take I like walk so that's definitely
took cat and then picked up but it does
we're like here we have the opposite
problem they should put in this cars the
cats
and you needed my gal just vocab we were
going to show the cat audition real
names let's see how long they got it hey
what's up hi my name is Maggie I have a
question for currys what is it like to
play such an interesting complex
character that is largely vilified by
the audience what's that word villain
vitac vilified hate it okay thank you I
knew one that worked um well actually
it's been funny because I've never had
so much hate mail when Shane no I get it
um I mean it i love to play this
character I I an especially last season
where it sort of starts to crumble lil
this and like the very last scene where
she basically figures out that she was
quite wrong um I cannot wait to see
what's going to happen her death in the
next season so yeah I love to play her
it's really great to play something that
I haven't played at all in my life like
I've always played nice people are in
this one is a little bit closer to the
real career hi there hi good hi I'm
Jonathan burger I have a question for
sophie Turner so the UM is a very
controversial character half the fans
want him to die half the fans think you
should forgive him because on one hand
he invaded Winterfell portrayed the
Starks and almost killed Brandon refund
but on the other hand he's really paid a
heavy price so if you're in Stan's
issues but you are how do you think
feel towards them how do you feel that's
a good question that's the question
we've been thinking about what season I
guess who last season I think I mean
Santa until holds it like episode 7 or
something she used her to be convinced
that he had killed rent and rent one um
and I mean he still betrayed her family
um I didn't almost kill ran a red card I
just killed two I still killed someone
but I mean he grew up with them there's
you know they've always had that family
wand is my kind of award but we're not
talking about that but I think they have
fun I think because she grew up with him
she still you know she she'll always
trust in him that little bit when she
gone our room she'll try to show up um
she lost in him that villainous but
everyone leaves you to my gosh
um sorry this is taking forever to
answer this question I think she likes
me machines and they go hey hey what's
up hello hi my name is jaime hammer back
up hi today we're obviously huge fans of
the show and especially to strong female
characters who says nobody likes this
thank you but those wonderful strong
women have really had a rough season
this is this season and some of the fans
have reacted negatively some of
America's really positively so our
question is I guess mostly directed at
this show runners and is a well seasoned
sits more overtly address and complicate
these criticisms by showing them as the
pitfalls of patriarchy rape culture and
other forms of oppression thanks yes
those guys dress put so much time in
addressing very similarly and then once
reading on iphone everyone has an actual
tag that is at the end of that answer
very much you know I think they're
trying to you know put together the best
best and most realistic would be the
wrong word but makes up those
personalities in that world after that
mythical top amenda the show takes place
and so things were not great for a lot
of people male and female yeah I feel
like this year on the show a lot of
characters has a really hard time not
just the women girls aren't the only
ones to do something first season I was
the only eunuch and village etsy on I
jumped on the bandwagon and all those
guys over with transfer yeah Hey oh my
god hi this question is for amazing I
was wondering since this is your first
big role how do you deal with all the
new found fame and attention to fans
first of all look at that sons of the
harpy that's great
oh my I think it's something that
happened very gradually and it wasn't
one day I woke up and had to sit in Hall
H and chapter houses houses people it
kind of happened over a long period of
time so I've got a really great family
around me keep you grounded when I'm
home and I'm the youngest of four so
whenever I'm home I'm reminded of that I
something don't get to set on the sofa I
don't get shotgun and I don't get to
choose what's on TV and I think the
final attention is wonderful Edmunds
something I'm really really grateful for
one sometimes very overwhelming oh but I
am like who every day from this life but
I think Willis are there's life that we
prepare ourselves in and thank you guys
hello hi oh nothing cuts like Valyrian
steel so imagine this is my Lyrian sword
oh no what you came here for
super Gwen my question is for the whole
cast and I just want to say the last
episode was so gratifying the first half
hour half hour was oh maybe so anxious
for season six but um what made me very
happy about this season was seeing story
lines cross seeing Tyrians show up with
Daenerys and seeing all the characters
that I loved interact with each other
and for each of you or any of you what
is a character that you haven't met that
you would like to me um in some upcoming
season I feel like we don't like to work
with colon a bit more because he's
hilarious yeah just saying next time on
this part in love and weighty month and
he's taking four seriously Conlon
everybody really but you will so thanks
question how can I curiosity how many
people on the hall read the books and
how many decades just watch the TV chef
excellent I have a question for David
the director if you can talk a bit about
the challenges and pressures of the
record of show this magnitude knowing
that every year the audience expects
something better and bigger its massive
when I did the red wedding episode was a
situation in which I had wrecked nemesis
just following the script ladies and
gentlemen I the right I directed season
two of they said we want you to direct
the red wedding I said okay I didn't
know what that was then I found out
exactly what it was nine months i had
this pressure my phone my shoulders how
the hell am I gonna do this I survived
that and came season five and I went on
in 5-10 oh my god how am I giving that
dragon Walker shave all those things how
I do it because the crew and the cats or
so tremendous it supports you there with
you in there with you all the time they
really make it happen for you so it's
really kind of thing where you know it's
like building a pyramid each brick at a
time one once done good time and the
talent is beyond measure on this table
and they make it all happen i can just
sitting them let them do it all
fantastic work but it's a great great
experience and for director there's no
better gift in to work with us or with
his cats work on the show just the best
hi my name is Joelle and I slept outside
the last two days to be perfect
I love you and how you bring your
characters to life my question is our
family favorite Gwendolyn how does your
character who's always unwavering loyal
and strong how was it for you to bring
down your walls and have that experience
and bantering and conversation with
Jamie do you have a preference on the
person you are and then that experience
oh I found it very interesting when I
read the books before and obviously than
the script about the basis of that
relationship about how we in a
mainstream TV show we got to see this
very unique very unconventional woman
enduring abuse from a man and then the
power lay in the fact that that got
turned on its head and the to develop of
a grudging respect for each other that
intense and close and doesn't have its
roots and sexuality and I'm thrilled to
see that at loss and I thought it was
very powerful modern representations
with them and long overdue yeah hi you
guys doing you guys are great you know
I've been watching you from season one
and then going on if it wasn't for all
of you you you know you wouldn't have
you know the great gasps you're so my
question right here is for a Greek
you're a good man you know even though
you do bad things very often
but uh you know now right next door Liam
and then you have so big you guys feel
like you have it says you hate that
characters that you know you know a real
life went there you know when you guys
having lunch or something like that
what's the question do we hate the
weekly characters in real life like the
ball turn and I mean you guys can I mean
you could like the voltage there an
awful bunch but yet it's definitely
interesting shooting it when you're as
real people and you know you've got the
balls looking very regal and sort
absolutely comfortable in this world of
terror and then you could stoke the sort
of sands have been just so violated
really I mean every every other day and
then you've got me a shivering mix in
the corner oh its own it's definitely
definitely there's been spontaneous fits
of laughter so when we cook when we're
shooting it without help but it's gonna
be great thank you thank you thank you
you dress up really well for the wedding
though I will say that you look great it
was even if anyone noticed it was robbed
stocks costume just FYI just to make it
a little bit more brutal yeah I didn't
notice hey hi I just like to thank you
all for the fabulous job at you guys do
my question is for alfie allen i want to
know what do you do to prep for the role
of leave like non-physical like gestures
that you do and besides the verbal like
stuff ugh so on the script yeah i mean
there was definitely a lot of acting
with the eyes which I which I which I
enjoy but um it's I wouldn't say I have
a sort of preparation for it I think if
the energy is not right on a day then
you're kind of messed up but I would say
that I definitely like to sort
decompress on my own a little bit
afterwards and me and you and are
actually really good friends which some
people can't find really hard to believe
and so we go out of this paper
things but in terms of soul preparation
you know preparing for oil I don't
really have a methods bill today hey my
name is Peter and I just wanted to thank
you for all that you do and your craft
and profession and I wanted to ask the
whole cast is there a moment that has
left an impact on you from the fans and
I just wanted to you know ask you what
has been a great moment from the fans
that you've received right now yeah
that's always a good one well well three
weeks ago number one fan oh no the
United States actually had a chance to
meet and he came up to me we shook he
took my hand looked me and put his hand
here my shoulder and my shoulder and
said you didn't kill Jon Snow did you
set off the Guantanamo was the interval
President Johnson was deader than dead
with my response grad wedding was his
favorite episode and kept telling me
that you keep killing all my favorite
character so I was at held guilty as
charged that was probably my most
exciting moment with fan do people ever
just yelled things out of you on the
street yeah you have to do the show I a
woman run of me with her hand at my
crotch love that but that was a great
party no at XI and XI by what do you do
I just wanted to check she thought
you're really method I don't speak to my
mother anymore
I think it's season six Paris should
start going stand up the marine cellar
hey you guys are great shows awesome
it's obviously an awesome time to work
in TV it's obviously an awesome time to
be a TV fan so much so that HBO shows
your show to test a new distribution
method by putting you putting the season
five finale in theaters for a couple
weeks past year any rumblings with that
happening again and for the cast what
did it feel like a movie star Colonel
weeks well quite a lot of them are movie
stars you know natalie Quentin live I
can't hear you as the game of drums
characters okay bringing in that world
to the big screen I didn't know you did
that they sold out everywhere oh no or
when they were on my hands well I have
to say that for televisions they are
like one hour movies big production
values everything about it is like
making a movie so Miss Strauss have you
heard any rumblings of them continuing
to do that in the future but you know I
don't know that was I think what you're
referring to is the imax for season four
and they you know I think there's
something that's very specific about
that imax experience and those
particular episodes I've really made it
suited to you know and I for people once
a sort of experience it whether that's
right or not for the future is yet to be
determined are there hi i annoy me and
this is a question for the whole cast we
have a few houses being
presented here but of the houses who are
here who would you want to see rule the
realm at the very end and whining well
it won't be the view Baratheon's I'm up
for Hodor you can do as good a job as
any street yeah I was always what is uh
huh always though he's trying to say I
would love to live in a world where I
said well to our news okay well as we
saw in early this season I think episode
2 of this season where it was the
election of the Lord Commander and and
Sam spoke for Johnson on putting forward
the narrative thread through the sea of
his men that by the end of it Sam was
out of there as a direct result of job
that women like Amanda so we saw that
was that skin acting job from sad right
he knows that Johnny's probably
objectively the best man for the job he
also has more gnarly on his and gillies
and babies home safely so you can see
that when Sam never has any power or
influence at all it may benefit people
at large for the bust is always very
little interest this is a really a type
of one last question so welcome and we
picked a winner
hey the bike is not like what happened
Stevens has been to start I was curious
whether or not Sam would it have any
clue as to where his character is going
forward from here and they haven't cut
off my head or burn my body so where am
I so that's been engine start oh hey oh
yes what was the question second tube I
where he it's an impossible to answer
questions wait is your question no
question his wife Ann well would know
where invention star kids is that
correct yes yeah well that's it's kind
of impossible to us patents motor sides
that's right now I wouldn't know what
kind of all all absolutely possible um
you guys thank you this has been such an
honor to be here in that way
this very exciting the panel is going to
stay and answer questions about HBO's
ballers is that right great
you